I said yeah I'm ok he said sir your eye
is hanging out the socket I believe what
are you serious right here because I'm
touching my thinking hat my face my face
and I was like yo that [__] in there
she did this [__] yeah so we um got this
Ottoman let me get a little bit of that
but there uh there's a local spring up
in the Blue Ridge Mountains of Georgia
so they made us some custom hot breath
labels so that's my gift to you if ever
you get thirsty I never get anything
thank you
you never get any man what no nobody
ever thinks about me Joelle Joelle I
like how you say my name yeah I was
trying to get biblical with it
I appreciate that no problem I look at
you inside very high regard man and I
receive him so much and you make me feel
like I made it because you dress the
part you know you like to the Walter
Cronkite of comedy whoa really
most definitely man you got it man last
time we talked we called you the hip hop
Howard Stern oh man now Walter Cronkite
a comedy we out here now it's only right
it is it's only right it take two to
make a thing go right and we did it I am
so excited and the last episode we did
it was hopper episode number 61 okay and
now we're in the 200s okay so work those
of you watching out there welcome to the
hot breath podcast this is your weekly
guide to comedy mastery the show where
you learn comedy from the pros this cat
right here since our episode so much has
changed but this guy if you don't know
came up right here in Atlanta Georgia
some of you may know him as the barbed
wire stripper who used to rub peanut
butter on his chest that's true some of
you may know him as honey bun the
comedian that used to wear wigs
stay yeah yep but most of you know him
as the one and only Jack thriller
welcome back to the hot breath podcast
my man honor to be back here yeah yeah
we him and we live we are alive come on
in how they say no homo
yeah how pozole enough to prove that you
not gay
sure um I guess taught me that one yeah
yeah that's crazy
we just got intimate right yeah it is a
really intimate so we in here now come
on now jungle fever give me zebra heat
you hear me make a mocha the swirl come
over there homies and hongki's yeah
okay everybody and trailers in the trash
man you better talk about it I like it I
like yo teeth and gold teeth we out here
you come on man you can do this all day
I'm not as good as you only I'm stepping
out ah now keep it 100 I uh those are
some jokes for my new comedy special the
trailer and the trap and the homing Hong
Ki I say that on my new comedies okay
okay cool trophy husband now available
at Joel buyers comedy calm the trophy
husband trophy husband what does that
mean are you married yeah man I'm
married now
oh yeah Pro wasn't married last time oh
you wasn't that mad with me not at 16
you and Mary no no no you found somebody
broke yeah man we made it
Wow I was married and divorced in the
same here my [__] went fast that [__] a
man cut what yes I got married on
Valentine's Day of seven seventeen and I
got divorced a Halloween of seventeen I
got a trick in a tree yeah
oh she couldn't hit me over the music
man scheanette she never even learned my
song you know what that means is
whatever you do inside life and whatnot
that people are attracted to that [__]
that's your talent and stuff they like
that person they like that person you
know say so
she was in in love with the idea of Jack
thriller and not who I really was when
the cameras go off you know saying so
you know it was what it was but that
doesn't make her a bad person it's bad
for me what's the difference between
Jack thriller on screen and off screen
uh it's really not a difference but then
when you went sometimes when you lit you
when you're watching people on TV you
automatically assume that everybody is
rich on TV right right like oh let's say
I'm not broke but they're on the same
token I ain't nobody to be like
splurging and making it rain and all
that old [__] that's not my thing I
worked really hard for my money and on
top of that I've came up broke so I just
never understood the concept of buying
things that you can't afford like the
the bags and all that she want to live
that type of lifestyle and it just
wasn't me oh no she want to spend your
money she want to spend my money she
didn't want to get much she did what she
would want to get money when I was
trying to teach her hiding
you know maneuver around and make her
own brand yeah she just wasn't with that
she just wanted to be handed to it you
know how'd you meet her one of my shows
[Music]
okay see a girl a girl at this
particular time in my life the girls
that came on my shows I was definitely
you know hitting a few of them
mm and what night it was no prerequisite
I know [__] like that but if you were
ready to go go gadget I was if they were
trained to go uh-huh dan yeah I was
gonna get them drugs and which which
shows us our party Oh [__]
okay see I met on there and it's just
instant chemistry yeah we was party but
first didn't turn to some booze ah yeah
excellent play on words did you smash
the first night uh I got my dick sucked
the first night and that's when I knew
that
she was the one for me Oh clearly
something about I can't put my finger on
it right right yeah not written I didn't
mean I didn't hit the first night but
the second time I did get my dick sucked
same [__] you know whatever makes you
happy whatever the time lemony is yeah I
you you waiting to give me the [__] but
I'm not waiting to go get no [__] oh
hey what's going on you coming over and
how long after meeting her did you
propose no I told it with my fantasy all
right for a woman to propose to me you
don't want she got on one knee no yes no
it's that just she proposed to you she
wanted to spend all your money
she came on your show like it seemed
like she was in it to win it the whole
time the whole time because she was
listening to what I was saying that I
wanted you know Brooke the devil answers
prayers to won't he do it yes he will
yes with gasoline drawers oh she burnt
you too man what taught me to true
meaning to Christmas we had a Charlie
Brown Christmas I learned a very
valuable lesson during a night and I
take my time when it came to
relationships now you don't saying just
even calling somebody a friend you know
and say you have to really earn my
friendship like I don't hang around
nobody I don't want to hang around guy
or girl you know is I'm really really
protective of my piece how long into the
relationship did you realize this was a
mistake
I think day two why after we got married
was she just create a flipped us grill
really she thought that she had me what
I wish she wanted me but I'm not the
type of person that you can trap because
I don't mind if I got to pay to get to
get you the [__] out my life I'm gonna
do that
you know I'm saying so you know she just
started to unravel and start acting
different and I will I look here [__]
I'm gonna tell you right now man that
[__] ain't gonna fly and I'm not
somebody that you could be fake around
too long you you it's like a vampire
walking inside of church oh here going
this blue mm-hmm and whatnot and that's
what happened just [__] sir I'm reveling
once again she's not a bad person just
bad for me
gotcha you know it's a very diplomatic
answer I've grow i've grown now and i
know it's all it's more about
accountability
you know forgetting pointing my fingers
there what you did to me and this ain't
[__] because of this or because this
person didn't know what did what did you
do I had to really point the fingers
back at myself man and you know allow
myself to grow and uh when I did that
there's self-reflection and stuff I
became a better person and things start
happening and positive in my life cuz I
wasn't looking for anybody to blame you
know yeah seems like you learned a lot
from it yeah I learned a lot from it it
definitely taught me who I am and why
that's good yeah yeah Suze worth it yeah
most definitely um yeah and then I'm
gonna in French that's what got me on
the toilet Martin won yeah when I when I
was going through our let [__] I didn't
know understand why I was I gotta get
married and divorce and why I get
homeless and have to move around five or
six times and then why I go blind and uh
III was depressed I didn't get why God
was allowing these things to happen to
me cuz I feel like I'm such a great guy
and I made myself so easy to love but
did when I when I went up and a sway in
the morning at Caroline's on Broadway
and I talked about what was going on
inside of my life you know the crowd was
very receptive to it to the point where
it scared the hell out of me and like
whoa so my pain is really entertaining
to them yeah and you know he threw it up
online and stuff and then um that's
where I see em seen and they showed it
to Martin Martin was like yo I want this
guy on my what and I'm like what though
out of millions of comedians that could
be only two
I'm the newest do own that consider in
comedy what I've been a comedian for
like 20 years now
but that's not what I'm known for I'm
known for the interview right exactly
and the battle rap and all kind of [__]
like that but yeah I got kind of got
away from the comedy because the other
things that I was doing was working and
when I did this is just automatically
let me know that it's time to just focus
on that stage and get my [__] together
so that's why I'm here in Atlanta right
now preparing I'm going to a I'm back to
the basics man I'm a man southern
audiences not you know I'm bringing the
page sharpening the sword again
sharpening this so it man you know I'm
saying and I'm uh I'm just in a really
happy place inside of my life right now
what a beautiful juxtaposition though
from almost like the lowest part of your
life you said you're homeless
yes homeless depressed what did you kind
of skip through that you know you kind
of he was like I was homeless I was
depressed was the lowest part of my life
and then this happened but what was that
moment you're are you living in your car
what do you have homeless worry you know
I wouldn't I wouldn't delivered in the
car homeless cuz I don't have a car
I wasn't on the street homeless uh-huh
you know I was a a staying at friend's
house mm yeah I was couchsurfing and
stuff trying to you know figure it out
and get it back together you're this
you're this top interviewer you're
interviewing all these celebrities and
yet you're homeless and depressed at the
same time and now we still doing the
interviews and whatnot while you're
watching me but you don't know what I
what I'm going through I'm blind to it
the same you went blind I went blind to
Blake completely yeah well to the point
where he's it's fuzzy and it was a deep
fog
I had detached my retina what yeah I got
in there was a whole nother relationship
after my marriage you married an eye
doctor the girl I would before I got
married she I needed somebody to talk to
after I had got my divorce so I just the
B of just for some friendship but that's
not what she had on her mind she thought
we was getting back
so she was sleeping on on my couch and
stuff you know spending the night
talking to me and everything but I'm not
knowing she's got this chip on her
shoulder because I didn't marry her we
were together like two and a half years
yeah and you know you know on my
birthday she was supposed to be making
me a birthday dinner and we were my
birthday I also felt on the same day I
do party and [__] so they're playing
what she's supposed to come the party
[__] have some funds from dranks and
and go back to the house and he cooked
my um my favorite meal which is staking
Lobster surf and turf so I wouldn't [__]
the lobster myself that was already done
and then I got when he got this big
these Big Ang t-bone steaks and [__]
when I got back from the party I had me
a threesome set up about 1:00 in the
morning
so she's supposed to cook this and leave
and go to her job or go to work or
something and go on she was on my couch
but ants in their gear laying out like
Marilyn Monroe she ate all my goddamn um
lobster yeah she ravished that
[__] I mean a mistake was still
frozen in in the scene
yeah I came over to the couch all a [__]
up and get the [__] out my goddamn mouth
you didn't made my birthday about you
[__] mmm yeah the [__] is wrong with
you
and she said what you saying I said
[__] get the [__] up and get the [__]
out my house right [__] now so she
put on the clothes and whatnot and she
walked over to me again and I guess you
knew they were just a clarification on
what I had see it one more time right
and I didn't know I was being set up
yeah she's like so say it one more time
I said [__] get the [__] up and get out
my house now and she hit me in my good
eye whoo yes I wanna she know I got one
good eye [__] hit me in my eye and uh
you know you ever play call of duty yeah
and you know how owner blood pop on the
screen that's what happened to my eye on
the inside of the eye but not on the
outside on the inside it were bleeding
on the inside so I'm instantly going
blind
right then and there boys and I'm
terrified
what the [__] for the Hamdi [__] better
goddamn for to cut my lights off
literally
so man I reach back from the pits of
hell and I've punched that [__] and
he'll [__] knows and I grabbed her by
her [__] neck like a pit bull puppy
and I bowled her into the wall like Fred
Flintstone
did I jumped up in the air like Bruce
Lee you know how you got it you put up
in the air like this
and he's come down ever but before I do
that [__] I might oh [__] I'm jacked
early I can't do that I stopped myself
from Bruce Lee in the [__] and so she
calls the police and the police got
there fast their [__] to the DOE and I
answered the door police were there they
were like oh [__] sir her are you all
right
I said yeah I'm okay he said sir your
eye is hanging out the socket because
I'm touching my thinking hat my face my
face and I was like yo that [__] in
there she did this [__] so she she saw
my I was hanging out like a yo-yo the
whole goddamn time they took my boy to
jail you know I did three days in jail
because none of my friends could bail me
out because I forgot don't none of my
friends know my real name dig some Jack
thriller 4 the last 10 years right
that's inside of my life and I realized
I don't have no real [__] friends I
have been committed to being Jack Oh
goddamn it back in jail back mind you I
never planned on going to jail Elvis oh
I didn't think that situation like this
whatever I'll pop out everybody knows me
in jail that made it weird to do it
because you don't st. know what I do
they know who I am it just seemed like I
would you know pop off like that so yeah
they know you jack trailer from this is
fit and you're in jail with a missing
eye
with a [__] hanging out the
goddamn socket yeah what they were they
like yo you got interview mofos yeah are
you okay yeah I'm cool I think and my I
heard it like a [__] oh so nice
um I go see the judge the judge looks at
my record and who I am and she I've seen
exactly she look at the girl record and
see who the [__] she is he and they're
more a [__] bunny tail [__] where
but when I'm watching the [__] with
them with the [__] thong up there
chickened out oh yeah chicken some
chicken yeah yeah yeah but once again
pointing a finger back at me it was my
fault for dating she can hear their
[__] yeah I put raise my standards when
it comes to dating people when I say
dating now I [__] she can hear it all
day
mmm how [__] she can see it off you
don't say it was for its dating no they
ain't loyal no she can here in st. Louis
not at all and it's a waste of [__]
time did you meet her on your show - no
I
yes I did but it was 16 a better oh my
is that when the depression kicked in
when you're like in jail and you're like
where am I at with my life yes I could
say it's just started right there yeah
and I had that lost my lost the
apartment
you know shortly after I got out of
there this things were starting to
spiral down I know it's kind of starting
to give up you know I'm saying so you
know I when I would walk outside and
people will recognize me and they were
it was like tell me how they felt about
this thing that I did online or that
thing that I did on Wilin out and
whatnot and it was just you know
recharge me man it made me want to fight
again and I got up off my ass and I
figured it out how low did it get were
you think about quitting or anything
like that
most definitely hmm I definitely thought
about quitting oh but it wouldn't end
equate to you know this all I had been
dedicated mine my whole life
it's comedy and entertainment what does
Jack driller quit to go do yeah I got no
skills I dropped out into the ninth
grade and we're not so what do you
quickly go do you know the only way out
is going straight through and I got up
off my ass and I just rebuilt myself
yeah that is the thing about us being
comedians as it is kind of like there's
no real backup plane like you can't go
back to McDonald's yeah Ari that's where
you would have to start over I guess yes
but you booked the sway thing yeah and
that's when I guess is was that like the
the first sign of light at the end of
the tunnel yeah most devilish way hair
didn't he's a friend of mine that's
great he's a friend of mine like I said
he heard about okay here nobody you
could just see I wasn't doing well and
it was public knowledge about my divorce
and stuff so you know and what happened
a lot of people day and people in the
industry knew what the [__] happens
though how long were you blind for yeah
what do you have someone to help you
around or would you people friends will
help me and you know but for the most
part I was trying to help myself
much like I never really liked asking
for help for anything so figure out
that's man that's so crazy because
perception being one thing versus the
other it's like because of me seeing you
I'm like oh man he's killing it these
interviews and you're working I see
you're like work you had like your own
weed company now or your own strength
use it on a straight g5 cultivation and
yeah I have my my own strand og killer
thriller oh oh I thought you're about to
call for that you're getting to do those
living purple wings you come to Atlanta
you got to eat some lemon pepper one
yeah yeah yeah yeah so you you have your
own weed strain now yep I'm on weeks
training I also work with another week
company called all-american papers man
when you started all-american records in
a couple of weeks and the first artist
is Jack gorilla mmm and I got it's a
three-album deal monogamously
promiscuous it's gonna be the first
project then gospel sex symbol and
that's the name of my band too and then
I'm doing a sleep with one eye open
thank goodness you got that one eye back
no I need that and no one was blind but
now I see and do these people just come
to you like it's it seems like no I go
get you go out and get it cuz I remember
when when we talked in the first
interview on here it's like you're like
yeah I moved to New York and I make it
happen with 50 cent like I made all my
success happened so is that what's
happening now well this is the grind
never stopped no I got I got up off my
ass you know I'm saying I got tired of
waiting on somebody else yeah and you
know and and I don't let people promise
me they just stick around and we don't
know IIIi go make it happen myself
nobody but me how do you cuz that's what
I'm doing with my comedy special the
trophy husband as we said earlier it's
like my goal is to all these Queens
releasing specials but it's like I
produced to myself you're not paid for
everything I'm releasing it myself with
the goal of crema an opportunity it's
been out I just released it last week it
was on my 10-year comedy anniversary so
now it's kind of like okay now how do
you get people to care you know what I
mean how do I get people to care Jack
break it up into pieces and stuff and
start you know do the same type of
marketing their Netflix would do and
whatnot you know in different pieces I
also like set up private viewings and
stuff and invite people out and
everything and make it a dinner and a
movie like Valentine's Day you should do
like a little Valentine's show we have
little specials where you know steak
dinners or some [__] like that and
everything people watch your stand-up
special you know a night with Joelle oh
I like yeah they didn't have to be every
day could be Valentine's Day so just
create the opportunity I like that make
a couple's thing you know cater towards
the ladies the ladies are the ones will
buy the comedy and I feel like with the
title the trophy husband I am I'm trying
to maybe get into that wedding world or
the marriage world like because there's
a lot of topical things than that based
on my personal experience with it that I
feel like could translate to more people
most definitely I think that is the
whole theme
that also know with you being the trophy
husband
you already dressed up like a groom mmm
you know I'm saying it you would have
wedding theme comedy shows oh yeah you
get you got to really put on put put on
it in the body that world and start
getting the sponsorships from different
wedding come Davis bridles and whatnot
and some kind of giveaway for wedding
dresses or something like that or hook
up with limo companies and stuff
everything that has to do with getting
married huh bra party promoter yeah then
you came up with a genius concept you
just getting lost inside of that world
man there's a whole bunch of checks out
there that's waiting knowing how do you
approach someone about a sponsorship or
how would I well you would go to David
Bridal or go to that limo company and
find out who the man is and you know
take a meeting with them and see if you
could sit down and show them you're your
stand-up special and tell them what your
ideas is to help market their a
situation now so and see how you guys
can't work together starting off with
you know maybe some kind of barter
system or any internet into a monetary
thing once they find out that it's
beneficial for the both of you are
mm-hmm they definitely have a database
that you could definitely use you know
that goes along with the whole trophy
husband I think so there's me coming up
that late of course no no of course
because last time we talked you returned
about you Rihanna your parity interviews
and you were like do this with
politicians and it's like it'll pop off
and I did it it didn't pop off but I'm
glad it didn't I mean it's still a my
YouTube but it's like I'm glad now since
that wasn't not released like three of
them you got you can't you got to keep
going but it ended up yeah it wasn't a
that wasn't that wasn't back then I was
trying to be this I was like trying to
be the all-american kid and all and do
political stuff but now not even I'm
more
I'm more like personal I'll talk about
my story I'm not trying to attach onto a
wave I'm trying to create my own most
definitely so that but you longer yes
yeah like the long road is harder but it
takes you farther so that's that's
that's my mindset I'm on so yeah all I
can know reach out I can connect with
all these different wedding companies
and just see if it's almost like I
become like a spokesman or shoot a
commercial maybe or something like that
okay
and maybe it's like I shoot a commercial
for the limo company and then there's
like an affiliate link that if anyone
that sees it and hires the limo company
through that affiliate link I get a cut
of that maybe yeah most definitely you
can do it that way and also you you you
focus on making these commercials funny
right of course no funny first make
funny funny fire birds and whatnot I
never get you booked on a lot more
wedding shows yeah and then you become
this wedding trophy husband guru on
ladies now if you did if you want the
reason why you're not married is because
you're not listening and the wedding
expert uh-huh yeah find a husband and by
coming to my seminars on and take it
from my husband I my egg on my expert
husband everyone start I'll be the
husband whisperer exactly the dog
whisperer yeah like say sorry let Joelle
exactly yeah even in the special I was
wearing the suit I wore at my weddings
I'm definitely embodying that whole now
it's just like turning up to eleven
maybe exactly exactly yeah so maybe
anyone listening if that sounds if you
want to work together it sounds like
howl at you boy that's how you do it
yeah we out here it only took me ten
years in comedy to be like hey I should
make money at this yeah but you you shot
pretty much the slam-dunk when it comes
to this Martin Lawrence thing I've got
to talk to you about this because like
he's I mean when I mean in our world the
comedy world I mean he's he's like the
goat to a lot of people I guess he is
that dude
so when you when you got that call what
was that moment like really it was
another moment like hey man God is
listening to me I'm supposed to be here
it's gonna happen
that was preparation meeting opportunity
yes I'm ready I'm ready look when can I
go let's go tomorrow I'm in mm-hmm so
you just you get on the call and is it
your agent or your manager is like hey
my Lauren we got it we got it we got it
man yo it's really happening
mm-hmm it's really happening it was that
type of vibe you know I'm still on cloud
now right now but how much stand if you
have you been doing six shows a night
but okay so you're you've been you've
been still working it okay yeah well I
mean it's a skill set that yeah if you
if you let it go it'll let go of you so
you've got to stay in that gym okay so
that's preparation again that if Martin
Lawrence like hey wait you'd open for me
and you're like all right I've got four
minutes and two of its crowd work so all
right I'll try my best Martin yeah well
you're ready for it so with these you've
interviewed also some of my like
all-time great comedians you know like a
Patrice O'Neal I remember Kevin Hart at
countless others and the Patrice O'Neal
one you actually got a number from a
comic and called him and we're just like
hey what's up I'd like to interview you
and then you may happen is that how
you've been able to make a lot of your
opportunities as you just find your way
to connect with the right people yeah I
go where said man I put myself all the
way out there I'm not afraid to be
rejected not afraid to be rejected
[Music]
Wow okay cuz that that's that's
something I need to get more proactive
at is putting myself out there more just
asking you know just being because with
this show you know this show has grown
to really be like Inside the Actors
Studio for comedians but I want to be
getting you know I want I want Sinbad I
want Kevin Hart you know I want the top
the biggest I've gotten I've got Cedric
the Entertainer so I got him and that
was another that was validation that
like okay we're on the right track this
is possible but now let's turn it
another gear here let's start get let's
get the Martin Lawrence's you know what
I mean like what do you have any advice
on how we can start to shift those gears
I don't find out what they're gonna be
at and you know just you know ask him
and work until it works mmm its
consistency yeah name of the game all
day in the hallway so what what are some
of the big things you've learned from
comedian like Kevin Hart for instance or
a Patrice O'Neal like what are some
things big takeaways you've learned from
being around these kind of people
Patrice O'Neal man the best advice he
ever gave me to have an opinion but
don't let the opinion have you know you
know that basically means that you know
you you can you can say somebody don't
be so arrogant to not be open to what
someone else is because they could teach
you something and give you a whole
nother perspective that you've never
even thought of so you know have an
opinion but don't let your opinion have
you mmm what about Kevin Hart Kevin Hart
one thing that I learned about from him
and it's I think that you know everybody
could take away because he's one know
most hardest-working comedians ever yeah
well and it's just be consistent be
consistent man and be resilient and you
know wake up early I would say just be
consistent and work work work hard
his ethic is unmatched what about a
little Duvall Lil Duval taught me how to
be Jack the ruler and you know this
basically not to believe everything I
hear and to you know always be
accountable he also helped me get it
learn how to work the internet he given
age on it he's really he's a genius when
it comes to social media yes
yeah and the music now the music
unbelievable topped all the way off but
we've been doing music
and he found one and he changed history
yeah he's part of Black History Month he
was a day they talked about him on
Jeopardy come on really
yes he was a Jeopardy question would it
what does that like to be seeing these
these cats you came up with because you
guys were in the trenches together like
y'all came up up together so what is it
like now I know your time is coming you
show you show me who your friends are
and I show you what your future mmm I
have yeah yeah so is this one of those
things man stop hanging around Jackie
[__] man and getting around
people that are doing things and you
know really maximizing off life and
understand that you only live once and
so you better go ahead and everyday live
it to the fullest and do what you really
want to do don't waste your time time is
the only thing you can't get back mm-hmm
and one of my favorite quotes from our
first interview was you had said I
believed in myself before anyone else
did oh yeah mostly like in comedy it can
be such like a lonely gradual process
it's like what how did you and you're in
those hard times early in the grind like
how did you overcome that self-doubt how
did you break through and just keep
going I don't I don't want to be that
that comedian or that just a person in
life where people just felt sorry for me
when I wanted to be a winner and I
wanted to win by all cost and whatnot
sorry I just made up in my mind that I
was gonna work hard and I wasn't gonna
look like no sucker no bum and whatnot
and I'm gonna get down on it so I just
made a choice to win I made a choice to
be happy by any means necessary this is
like a mindset yeah it's a mine isn't
all mine it's all mine sighs oh my is
the Auto Wars meant - ooh can you expand
on that you know like I said you you you
have to you can wheel yourself into a
great situation but you have to always
be able to see yourself inside those
successful situations and whatnot and
anything starting and visioning on how
to get there and you you can't allow
yourself to be distracted there's
come in all different types of forms
friends vices situations backup plans
you have to stay on the path
remember what you came here for and
follow through don't take the easy way
out follow through don't look left don't
look right and damn sure don't look back
only way out is through mmm and he's all
mental you even said like visualize you
like picture and success they make like
offenses I wrote down set of goals last
year and one of those was I'm gonna be a
major a major of tour and I was gonna
get a Netflix deal and I was going to
get a record deal these are I have
friends I could call up to you right now
and tell you did I tell you that I said
that's what I was gonna do and I did it
well I got friends that I could I could
call right now and I told him that I was
gonna come up in New York and I was
gonna meet 50 cent and I did it I got
friends right now that I told I was
gonna be on wiling out and no manager no
hmm
I did it man so you you got to see
yourself inside that situation man
because there's nothing only thing the
difference between you and somebody else
is that they just they deserve to be
ahead of you because they actually try
and you was thinking too much waiting on
the right time but man sometimes waiting
on the right time well you you would be
dead for whatever the right time
yeah even setting the intention I found
to be super like last year was the first
time I set like actual measurable goals
and like one of them was I want to
record a comedy album this year it just
happened that one of the fans my
podcasts had a production company and
was like hey we can make this a comedy
special instead of just an album but
setting the intention to Craig now and
kind of put the whole thing in motion
to now become the trophy husband but if
I didn't first set that goal it would
have never happened what happened yeah
but as comedians we can get lost in just
well it is what it is but I feel like
now it's time and
the opportunity is bigger than ever for
us to create our own success that's
absolutely great and do you have any
tips for comics who are out there on the
hustle and are just like well how can I
start to get my own thing going you know
get your be consistent in so many
different ways to get yourself out there
do you know these things that are
available to you that you know Bruce
Bruce didn't have like social media
right right
like a lot of older comedians don't have
like big s following they had to go out
there and make it happen so but we have
access to Facebook Instagram Twitter all
these the tic-tock all these different
ways to promote yourself if you don't
make it a day you ain't opposed to make
it so just make it happen it work you
gotta do the work I remember when I was
in acting classes with Robert Townsend
he said honey bun yeah no shortcuts you
got to do the work Wow
and what about 50 cent what have you
learned from working with him he said
don't ever do business with somebody
that don't respect you hmm don't ever do
business with somebody don't respect you
uh we're supposed a he's talked about
when he was just talking about the other
day when he found out that I was on them
- Martin Martin is his favorite comedian
and he was just like a man is you got to
get ready - anything wrong with you
changing because people around you are
going to change and you know feel like
that there was part of your success in
me actually having to do with it because
what success breeds envy uh entitlement
and jealousy hmm
it's another word I'm looking for
it's this 3mv and entitlement it's not
well envy and jealousy I guess are the
same thing mean be entitlement no no no
I'm not 50 cent yeah yeah of course yeah
yeah people will change up on you when
you get when you get successful people
start to switch up but like you says
people you surround yourself with
so you being in the same room as Martin
Lawrence is kind of like oh I'm in the
right place [__] me what's going on I
got long-lost cousins and [__] from 20
years ago warning them to because I
release you
everybody thinks you're like co-star and
you guys are like gonna you're this
multi-millionaire all of a sudden
they're like let me hold some Jackalope
right right right
not yet exactly so maybe land in this
plane here do you have any other advice
for comics or any other lessons you've
learned that you can kind of impart onto
us young ambitious Souls there's no
blueprint to it I would just say go up
three three four times a week turn turn
there five minutes in the ten minutes
there ten minutes in the 15 and so on
and so forth just to be consistent
mind your business no worried about
whatever everybody else doing and mind
your goddamn business today this [__]
ain't got nothin to do with you preach
and keep on writing keep on writing and
don't sweat the dumb [__] things that
are petty that you know you don't really
really have to address like if somebody
really pissed you off that much it's
tough [__] what i'ma call her today
you know I'm saying we move on with your
life and be positive be be be their
beacon of light and whatnot man cuz you
don't never know where who's gonna turn
into who one day they can help you ya
know yourself I've learned that up ten
years into this game now is you just
never know who's gonna be what and where
then that one that one comedian that you
kind of just were rude to at that open
mic eight years ago now is like the
biggest Booker in town or is now like
running their own show on TV like you
just never know you never know just
always be a good person to be nice and
you were the first the first time we met
up you didn't even know me we kind of
reconnected when you did the show at
Uptown
and then I just got referred I think
Ronnie Jordan was the one who was like
Joel's good people and then you were
like all right well if he says or
whatever you know you just kind of did
it just based on the people you surround
yourself with well if they like them
then I'll probably like and now the
hip-hop Howard Stern in the Walter
Cronkite a comic like that oh and you
said last time you wanted to be like
like a Lorne Michaels are like a Kenan
where you want to start purveying these
young talents are you still thinking in
that mindset also cuz I'm ready when you
are
that's real yeah like I said I'm just
getting back on my feet and stuff right
and I'm just getting out there and I got
a really focus on Jack cuz I gave it to
the streets for a long time for free and
I've helped a lot of comics I've him a
lot of DJ's I've helped a lot of rappers
and whatnot but I ain't really helped
Jack and I'm right now I'm pouring from
it oh I just got finished give my glance
back fool because I was more for me
because I think that's the right mindset
it seems like it almost came full circle
for you there I'm excited for you man
because it does sound like you've been
giving giving giving giving giving
giving giving giving giving and it seems
like now it's gonna start returning to
you exactly you feel that like that wave
most definitely brought of money so you
want to change address is changing yeah
I'm really excited no more no more
ex-wives no more chicken heads now
you're gonna marry her like your chick
married you she wants you for the money
holy hell oh okay I don't need me for
nothing but but a companionship and when
we get together we celebrate our life is
being successful together cuz I don't
want your money i but I just want to be
able to focus on doing what I'm doing
and you don't be thinking about what you
you
in here from just getting what you can
get mm-hmm you know yeah man well yo
let's let's wrap this up man this is
this is a fun interview
I do feel that way thank you so much man
appreciate you I feel like it went on
like oh I'm getting better it I feel
like cuz in interviewing it's a lot of
like you like listening early on you
know cuz I do so much research for
people it was almost like a script where
I'm like okay we're gonna go here and
then here and then here so whatever they
say we're going here next but now it's
it's kind of more organic but I felt
like this kind of went on like a
high-energy wave and then we got like
serious and then it kind of feel like it
kind of went on a whole rollercoaster
most definitely a most definite bro you
an excellent interview bro you know that
means a lot coming from you a
professional interviewer excellent
interview all right so let's um is there
anything else before we get out of here
he's on IG live right now for the
culture is uh is there anything else
that you want the world to know I just
really appreciate everybody dan has been
you know dealing with me thus far and
you know the best is yet to come let's
get it poppin baby where can they
support you and at Jack thriller man on
Instagram or follow the leaders [__]
or Martin Lawrence man I'm from here
right now to to me yeah it's going down
in a major way watch party and [__]
every Monday 16 abettor we're doing
their own one-off episodes
South by Southwest man Jack Willis stage
hosted by myself and hit crack once I've
been feats every Austin Texas March 21st
you know all independent artists they
want to slot email me at 16 a better at
Gmail and get social at today and
whatnot and ah let me see once again
look out for that my L man R&B comedy
and whatnot it's gonna be amazing I got
a lot of dope ass features it's gonna be
on there so you know look out for that
I'm saying bye you gonna see me store
hear me drop music within the next 3-4
weeks you have like you're like of your
own network I my own network bro I'm not
waiting on nobody put me on my cell
phone
all right well the final thing every
guest does is they look into the camera
they say who they are and why comics
should listen to hot breath podcast hey
what's up what's up did she boy Jack
Doyle aka I gotta might say my man akdy
3000 aka Frank lotion hey Kate jack a
velly man hey and our comics should
definitely watch hot bro podcasts
because it's informative
it is the comedy Bible up-to-date and
you find out there who we and where and
why and if it's here you know inside on
the high prime podcast I prep podcasting
hyper a podcast with my man Joe let's go
my man Jack thriller thanks Ben on how
breath again me I appreciate you man we
made it let's go that's good stuff yeah
I feel really good you amazing bro
[Music]
I breath